les chéris vous avez vu ce qui a
organisé le Pôle Emploi votre prochaine
maison ils organisent un ping-pong pour
recruter des gens c'est un truc de fou
demandeur d'emploi et recruteurs ont
passé la matinée à jouer au ping-pong
ensemble ensuite ils ont mangé ensemble
puis les entretiens professionnels bonne
idée moi je trouvais très bien alors
j'ai envie de faire pareil avec vous
on va jouer votre avenir professionnel
au ping-pong c'est très simple
c'est mort vous allez vous affronter en
deux points gagnants de toute façon à la
fin c'est vous qui gagnez
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
si vous gagnez c'est un point par point
si vous gagnez je vous le dis
c'est très simple
vous avez double de salaire aujourd'hui
[Musique]
si vous perdez c'est divisé par deux
est-ce qu'il y a quelqu'un dans le
public qui est très fort au ping-pong et
qui veut m'affronter ah d'accord parce
que
les mecs
amener la petite table amenez la petite
table
si vous gagnez le point si vous gagnez
le point c'est multiplier maintenant
cette semaine
c'est juste les points que je vais
mettre un peu d'huile de jojoba et tu
seras reparti pour 5 ans allez
les séries on y va allez c'est parti on
y va maintenant
[Applaudissements]
voilà
service
tu as perdu aussi
[Applaudissements]
tu conserves tu conserves ton ton
ma chérie c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
elle est venue elle doit venir
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mauvais joueur
[Applaudissements]
conservé par 2 / 2 Yassine
c'est trop petit cette table là
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il méritent
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention
[Applaudissements]
dans le public qui veut me défier non
mais quelqu'un
vous êtes des chèvres c'est bon
il joue vraiment bien les gars
qui est sérieux
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
merci mon Lucien tu as quel âge mon
chéri 23 tu habites où aujourd'hui du
côté de 50 ans normalement donc dans
l'impression que tu es en cavale toi
comment tu as deviné Cyril
[Applaudissements]
allez moi chérie on va jouer pour on va
jouer pour un cadeau et tu peux sauver
des chroniques
toi tu gagnes un cadeau
[Applaudissements]
tu te fous de ma gueule
c'est pas mal tu vas aller mais on va
t'offrir un cadeau quand même
[Applaudissements]
un smartphone un smartphone c'est pour
moi les mecs vous avez vu c'est le chien
c'est le mauvais exemple
est-ce qu'il y en a un qui pense qui
joue mieux que Géraldine maillet les
chéris sinon on fait représenter par
Géraldine
[Applaudissements]
je crois qu'elle nous arnaques quand
même non non
[Applaudissements]
deuxième essai bah oui mais je remets la
balle je remets la balle c'est exprès
[Applaudissements]
pour l'instant les chroniqueurs ne sont
pas sauvées
vous allez prendre un représentant
il va avoir 5 chances en général vous
choisissez qui est-ce que vous
choisissez quelqu'un du public est-ce
que vous choisissez
[Applaudissements]
c'est où Géraldine gagne elle sauve tous
vos salaires pour bien c'est tout mon
divisé par ciao
taisez-vous au courage
[Applaudissements]
il est pas bien
dernière dernière attention
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]